bill maher said the following bill maher
said
uh criticizing for telling jada pinkett
smith to put a wig on it right after the
oscar slap he says uh i mean alopecia
it's not leukemia okay
alopecia is when your hair falls out
there are worse things he returned to
the subject later in the show stating if
you are so lucky in life
as to have uh
that be your medical problem just say
thank god it's not life-threatening it's
part of for most people eighty percent
of men fifty percent of women it's part
of aging uh mark continued aging is
trust me i know it's the degeneration of
the flesh it happens to all of us and
you know just put on uh f and wig on
like everybody else at the oscars if it
bothers you so much the tv host has been
heavily criticized for his comments
which have branded hateful okay what
bill maher says you he knew he's gonna
get he he when he wrote the lines when
he knew he was gonna say those those are
gonna attract heat but he doesn't care i
don't think
no he doesn't care i think this this
speaks to a lot of uh
you know when they
they made it they have an open marriage
i guess you know and so they made a joke
earlier in this in the in the show about
uh
you know
um them having an open marriage and that
kind of thing so
you know i don't know
it's it's one of those things where and
she went on you know i think they're
under a lot of stress that they seem to
be under
uh jada in in will it seem to i hope
maybe he gets some help i think he is
getting some help isn't he or anything
or i don't know if he is or they said
it's healing season is what jada put out
it's healing which i don't know what i
think they should get a divorce i'm
convinced they should get a divorce i
i'm convinced don't be surprised if in
the next 6 12 24 months you get a tweet
or an instagram post from both of them
saying
we have decided to go our own separate
ways after being together for 25 years
we love each other
and but here's what we're doing this is
the love of my life but you know
uh you know we've whatever you'll see
something like a bazel script
kevin let me ask you while we're on this
topic and tom lives in l.a so and pat's
from there so he's probably has a strong
opinion you moved out of la
five years ago yeah but i mean
you're farley you're a farley you've got
inroads with hollywood you know all the
hollywood stars yeah you know we're
talking about the oscars the night of
the year for hollywood i guess what's
your take on the wokeness in hollywood i
don't want you to get canceled here
kevin
what's your take on just what's
happening and how left they've gone and
how you have to worry about what you're
saying and you mean you got the hell out
of there not for political reasons i
don't know but just your take on
hollywood these days i know that i
wasn't uh you know i'm not i'm not
crushing in hollywood i don't have
anything going on i'm not competing with
brad pitt for the role of troy anymore
all right i'll get my you know my hawaii
five always every once in a while or you
know i'll do an episodic you know once
in a while yeah curb you know those guys
were great
you know um but no i'm not you know so i
decided let's do some stand up i focus
on my stand up and let's you know i get
the roll whenever i can get the role
because yeah it got to be weird
with a lot of their politics in in
hollywood you know it just got to be a
little scary
you know with this cancel thing going on
if you if in and it's such a like if you
think even a little differently you know
then you're you're not in the club and
it is a club i mean hollywood is very
much of a country club and who's running
the club is it the is it the
billionaires is it the studios is it the
producers the rich people the studios
the people with all the money you know
and it's falling apart though the money
in the control and it is a club
that you are either in or you're not i
mean it's like a country club i mean we
don't want this guy in i mean do we want
this guy in we don't want this guy in
and it's kind of behave it's like high
school it's it's very much gossipy
there's a lot of gossip you know i don't
know gossip is so corrosive
you know i don't like to even when i
feel like gossiping i don't like to
gossip about things and that's the whole
town is a gossip mill
you know and so
that's a corrosive thing on your soul
so that's why people like oh god this
town is so gross
you know because everybody's just
talking about it everybody what's your
take on that zenner you live there yeah
hollywood pat you made a little comment
there but hollywood just feels different
la feels different it's not as glamorous
i think the glamour's gone i mean that's
the sad thing for me you drive down
sunset boulevard or you drive through
beverly hills it's still great believe
me it's not that bad i mean and now that
the pandemic is pretty much over
restaurants are full there is a buzz
there's an energy but if everybody
remembers it's kind of that first time
they go to california and how they feel
the ocean's still beautiful there's
still a lot of great places to go but
just that that spirit in the air just
doesn't feel um is great and to me the
glamour part of it it seems like
hollywood
is okay not being glamorous anymore and
i don't know why and i miss that and i
think the rest of the world the rest of
america looks for hollywood for that
it's a release and they're so obsessed
about bringing up all these things that
people already have to deal with in
their life and they're getting bombarded
with it every single way they turn and
hollywood should be something else a
diversion and they've gotten away from
that and it's unfortunate plus the whole
business is changing streamers are
taking over we saw that during the
oscars now that's good because there's
so many more places to make content and
if you've got product and if you have
something you want to pitch you've got
15 to 100 places you can take it if
you're an actor you can stay busy so
it's still great the world needs the
content that hollywood produces but it's
unfortunate you know i've just told
myself
until the whole until [ __ ] hits the fan
i'm totally still good with la and we're
lucky for where we live right so it's a
great place to bring up kids you know
near the water in a very safe community
so we're blessed and we're lucky with
that but and i and i love la i really do
and i'm involved in it and i'm out in it
every single day and i i part of me sad
because i grew up in a small town in
minnesota i'm from the midwest too kevin
and i wanted to get to california i
wanted to get to l.a and i'm sure you
growing up in iran there was this
magical course about hollywood i'm
working on a new project right now i'll
be able to share some stuff later in a
couple months with someone a very very
high profile person who also grew up in
iran and came to america and made a big
name for himself but it was all because
of hollywood he wanted to get there
beverly hills california and hollywood
so i am an eternal optimist i always
assume the best is going to come and i'm
never going to let it bring me down i'm
just a little bit sad that it wasn't
what it was 25 years know what if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]